hey Mom can you drive me today are you
ready to go now yeah just give me like
five seconds
[Music]
by that logic we should just occupy
every Country Joe I agree with you Lila
thank you Ziggy how do you agree with
Lila oh [ __ ] excuse my brain for knowing
what not to say
I know it'll get better
cats thanks for tuning in
Mom did you open my doorbells [ __ ] I'm
sorry did you try to open the door while
I was live streaming what's live
streaming that's where I have 20 000
followers and I'm validated and I'm
starved which is Terror hard to get just
make sure you don't play the blues what
white people playing blues music this
cultural appropriation I play classic
folk rock with alternative influences I
don't know what that means and then you
called the police I called them you're
in the right place you're safe and
you'll have two beds for as long as you
need he's my little nine Shining Armor
well it's true kids are just pure love
you know what I mean
what the hell are you doing installing a
red Beacon lights with people know when
I'm live streaming and by people I mean
you
instead of politics you think I'm stupid
no no I didn't say that I brought you
this hat Kyle it was my son's but he no
longer wears it I don't know what he
wears anymore
[Music]
those boys your age can't bring
themselves to be kind and you can't help
yourself you're a special person
Ziggy are you happy I think so why are
you asking me because I'm reading this
article about teen suicide and it's
highest in your age group okay thanks
Dad mom's home
when you were a little boy you're my
little Ally your life is going to be
happier you were going to be one of the
good ones
there's something switched in you
you stopped being interested in anything
outside your own little world
sorry about that
can you take me to school are you ready
to go right now I'm right here dude
[Music]
[Applause]